So my favorite context aware application is Netflix. So,
I use the smartphone application to scroll through content
and find what I want to watch. Then I Chromecast
it to my TV. The application understands that context
switch. So my smartphone application then becomes my remote
control, as I'm focused on watching the content on
my TV. It's really cool how it switches between
a media player, and a remote control depending on
>> Yeah.
>> What you're doing with it.
>> And my favorite context aware app
is, Agent. We mentioned this earlier. It's a fantastic
application that takes advantage of, really processing those signals
that are generated by a whole bunch of sensors.
And making sense of them, so that I don't get
disturbed when I'm sleeping, when I'm in meetings and,
and on and on. Not only that, but it
uses location sensors and it even tells me where
I might have parked my car. Which is really cool.
>> Yeah.
>> And the, and the, and the coolest thing
is, I don't even have to interact with this application,
for it to work for me. Which is another thing I love about it.